Reportedly written in just six days by John
Hughes, Ferris Bueller's Day Off captures
a single, magical day in the life of a high
schooler who understands, well…
“Life moves pretty fast.
If you don’t stop and look around once in
awhile, you could miss it.”
Ferris outsmarts his parents and his principal,
steals a classic car, gets the girl, gives
his best friend self-confidence, dines in
a fancy restaurant, takes in a baseball game,
and even sings a Beatles song on a parade
float.
“They all adore him.
They think he’s a righteous dude.”
So why is it that we only ever got that single
movie?
Here are some reasons why we never got to
see a Ferris Bueller sequel.
“Bueller?
Bueller?
Bueller?”
It didn't need one
Director John Hughes and star Matthew Broderick
stayed in touch for a few years after filming
wrapped on Ferris Bueller's Day Off and talked
about ideas for a sequel.
According to Hughes, in those proposed movies,
Ferris would, quote, "be in college or at
his first job, and the same kind of things
would happen again."
The two ultimately decided that a sequel like
that would basically be a lame rehash, because
the original movie was, quote, "about a singular
time in your life."
“Incredible.
One of the worst performances of my career
and they never doubted it for a second.”
John Hughes moved on
Hughes created a string of classic teen movies,
including The Breakfast Club, Pretty in Pink,
and Sixteen Candles —and Ferris Bueller's
Day Off was just about the last one.
After Bueller, Hughes only made one more teen
movie in the '80s, 1987's Some Kind of Wonderful.
Then he shifted to family fare like Uncle
Buck and Home Alone, and more grown-up films
such as She's Having a Baby and Planes, Trains,
and Automobiles.
“Where’s your other hand?”
“Between two pillows.”
“Those aren’t pillows.
Ahhh!”
Busy Broderick
Matthew Broderick was one of the biggest stars
of the late '80s, and a big part of that was
because of his role in Ferris Bueller's Day
Off.
In the five years afterwards, Broderick starred
in an eclectic bunch of movies, from contemporary
dramas like Torch Song Trilogy and Project
X to comedies like Family Business and The
Freshman, to period pictures like Biloxi Blues
and the Oscar-winning Civil War epic Glory.
With all that on his plate, Broderick just
didn't have time to make a sequel.
Hughes didn't dig sequels
There aren't many sequels in the Hughes filmography.
While his screenplay for the first Vacation
movie is based on a true story he wrote up
for National Lampoon, he skipped having anything
to do with European Vacation — though he
did return to write Christmas Vacation.
“Ahh...It’s good.
It’s good.”
That's the only sequel Hughes ever worked
on.
He reportedly toyed with a follow-up to The
Breakfast Club for years — which would've
presumably been called "The Lunch Bunch" — but
couldn't ever come up a legitimate reason
to get those five characters back into the
same room again.
Similarly, he just couldn't conceive a worthy
Ferris Bueller sequel.
“You’re still here?
It’s over.
Go home.”
Second movie second thoughts
In spite of his sequel aversion, Hughes still
mapped out his ideas for Ferris Bueller 2.
He shared some of them with Jeffrey Jones,
who played evil Principal Rooney.
At a Hughes tribute event after the director's
death in 2009, Jones claimed Hughes had told
him some of his ideas for Bueller 2, but all
Jones would say was that it was supposed to
be set in Hawaii, and that it fell apart because
Broderick ultimately wasn't interested in
reprising his role.
What about a sequel series?
In the fall of 1990, NBC debuted a single-camera
sitcom called Ferris Bueller, which operated
under the odd conceit that the show depicted
the real life characters on which the movie
version of Ferris Bueller's Day Off was based
on - and they hated the movie.
“This is television.
This is real.”
The show, which was pretty much a standard
high school sitcom notable only for the participation
of a young Jennifer Aniston as Bueller's sister
Jeannie, didn't attract much of an audience
and was cancelled halfway through the 1990-91
TV season.
“Not to worry, Cameron.
I fixed it.”
There were two sequels... sort of
Though there was no full length sequel, Matthew
Broderick did sort of reprise his role as
Ferris Bueller on two occasions.
In John Hughes' 1988 relationship comedy She's
Having a Baby, the end credits roll as a rapid-fire
montage of celebrities throw out their ideas
for what Kevin Bacon and Elizabeth McGovern's
characters should name their new baby.
Among the cameos is Matthew Broderick, clearly
in character as Ferris Bueller.
“Jim.”
And in 2012, Broderick returned again for
a two-and-a-half minute Honda Super Bowl commercial
which features numerous nods to the movie.
He may not have technically been playing Ferris
Bueller, but this could be the closest we
ever get to a sequel.
“He bought it.
How can I handle work on a day like today.”
Fan script
In 2011, an amateur screenwriter named Rick
Rapier went viral when he released the first
12 pages of a Ferris Bueller sequel script
he'd written.
The plot: Ferris Bueller is now 40 years old
and is a motivational speaker, a la Tony Robbins.
But he's incredibly overworked, so with his
business manager — Cameron Frye — he takes
a day off.
It couldn't gain much traction in Hollywood,
however — Rapier hadn't been hired by anyone
to write the script, or even asked.
The script was never purchased, and Rapier's
15 minutes of internet fame were up.
“I changed my mind.
I want you out in front of the school with
her.
I’d like to have a few words with you, by
God.”
Maybe they'll do one someday
Alan Ruck, who played Ferris's best friend
Cameron, has spoken about a loose idea for
revisiting the movie's characters in the distant
future.
The plot: Cameron, still a sad sack at 70,
commits himself to a nursing home even though
he's in relatively good health.
His old friend Ferris gets wind of it, busts
him out, and the two old men have a blast—going
into the city, hitting a strip club, et cetera.
At the end, Cameron dies.
With Ferris Bueller 30 years in the past and
both Ruck and Broderick in their 50s now,
that means this Ferris Bueller Returns could
hit theaters sometime around 2036.
“I said it before and I’ll say it again.
Life moves pretty fast.
You don’t stop and look around once in awhile,
you could miss it.”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!